Hey
I haven't seen you in a uniform for a
while yeah that was on purpose
hmm can you tense me
Arian General Patton and Annie on bus
they say
people watch the Boston Marathon
behaving yourself
we've got to decide who's running this
and we have to decide quickly
it's terrorists we'll take it and let's
get it evidence for it started right
over there
clock is ticking the world is watching
suspect seen on the surveillance cameras
on two bombers we got to find these guys
before they do this is someone else we
can't have our citizens on the streets
with all these threats every inch of
this city is getting searched we're
shutting it down
a taxi picked up a guy matching
Whitehouse description could be he's on
his way to D or are they more bombs are
there more bomb I want a lawyer no no I
have rights you ain't got [ __ ]
sweetheart
when I saw today good versus evil
love horses Hey
on one thing you had to fight back with
love
wrap arounds about each other
he'll think there's any way that
together we'll win
why are you laughing that's just I look
like a clown
it's the color I'm basically a crossing
guard you got my whistle my stop sign
come here give me a kiss